[Music]
we saw a few patients that were blind
yesterday and now they are seen today I
have personally done surgeries on more
than hundred thirty thousand patients I
grew up in a very small village
northeast of Nepal I lost my brother and
sisters to such simple diseases that
could have been cured by modern medicine
and that's why it has become my mission
in life to be a doctor for the poor
there are so many people that I can help
I am dr. sondik rue it
I am the naphtha moralist and executive
director of the till instead of
Ophthalmology here in Nepal which caters
to about 500,000 to 1 million people
many Nepalese and rural releases are
losing their eyesight 90% of the blind
actually lives in this part of the world
cataract as a disease can cloud your
vision for life surgery is the only
treatment for cataract
so I traveled to remote villages all
over my country since I know from my own
experience people who are marginalized
both because of economy and geography
they are the ones who suffer a lot the
longest that I have travels is walking
forever Sundays with the equipment's I
have these big eye opening stables it's
kind of a moment where I've seen
hundreds of patients you're probably
working for 13 hours a day everybody
thought I am crazy and mad we wanted to
find surgical technique and a surgical
system which was cost-effective
intraocular lenses which are a must part
of modern cataract surgery used to cost
250 to 300 dollars we worked very very
hard to bring down the cost of these
lenses to less than $3 by being able to
manufacture in Nepal
[Music]
I've seen thousands for each patient
story touches my heart and it is the
expression of these patients who have
been blind yesterday and suddenly they
come out and see everything in front of
them see people they loved and they
changed the perspective to life in a
fraction of second we have been seeing
some good effects of our work in the
last 10 years we have trained nearly 650
doctors I believe that we can do this
all over the world and I want to spend
the rest of my life raising money for
many of these hospitals this is why this
medical intervention is so beautiful and
so powerful my patients are my life and
soul
[Music]
you